Oh, this reminds me actually. I saw um
I saw Nikki D.
Nikki D. Nicki D. He takes a screenshot
of this Knox tweet
where Nox says, "So, the guy who
allegedly raped a 15-year-old in a
brothel, which he was never alleged,
went to diddy parties, called the cops
to do wellness checks and XGFs, support
mass rapists, supports Houthies,
pedophiles, supports Hezbollah, sex
slavers. You're saying he was a sex pest
about the new Hassan thing. And Nick
says, "You should go back to watching
little cartoons. What the [__] is this
tweet even? Are you Hassan Piker's
controlled opposition?" And he got
absolutely he got swarmed for this,
guys. And he was posting he was
co-posting
about how Oh, is someone is someone like
buying anti-Hassan bots on Twitter? Why
is Why is everyone Why is everyone
coming after me? Why is everyone coming?
Someone's buying anti-hassan bots on
Twitter. Why is everyone coming after
me? No, this is the bed you've made.
Just the bed you've made, you fat
[__] idiot. N just replies here. You
see the 80 replies and no major retweets
to this tweet? This is insane. Lau.
Yeah. FWNN update.
FFWN
update.
Dude, you and Knox shouldn't be at odds.
Just chill a bit. I know you're no
Hassan defender, but Knox absolutely
hates the guy for good reason, too. So,
the the quoteunquote good reason here is
that Knox claims, no one can verify this
because obviously Knox is anonymous.
Knox claims that his cousin was killed
by Hamas in October 7th.
Knox claims his cousin was killed by
Hamas in October 7th. He was an IDF
soldier killed by Hamas in October 7th.
So, that means that no can just lie
about Hassan. I guess that means that
not get to, you know, actually Jews have
been victims. They just get to lie about
everything. That's what I think. Me
personally,
why are you defending Hassan? Why
weren't you aborted? Why weren't you
aborted?
Hassan is not going to [__] you.
Shocking, I know. Also, you shouldn't
wish people to die. I'm pretty sure it's
breaking to
defending an evil man who gets off on
harming dogs. Let's not ignore the fact
he's a terrorist sympathizer. Provides
material support to terrorists. Legit,
you have no idea what this phrase means.
Oh [__] he went to pedophile parties,
too. This you choose defend at FBI. This
guy's asked to come look at his hard
drive. He's fighting it down. He thinks
he's a bots and he's still fighting with
him. Like it just goes and goes. Um,
yeah. Wait, here's this other tweet
about it. Genuine question. Are people
botting negative for comments? Nobody of
value even retweeted this and I have no
idea where the brigading is coming from.
Wow. It's almost like um you've been
able to lie for like the whole last year
and a half. It's almost like Nick's been
himself lying for the whole past year
and a half
and as such has gained an audience and a
following on Twitter who believe the
game is that they lie about Hassan and
attack anyone who doesn't.
It's almost like that's his entire
audience now because he latched on to
someone who also does that. Mate is
trying to to hear some of the tweets
he's getting he's crying about. Yeah. Me
sowing me reaping. Mate is trying to
fend the Hamas Diddy Per just say you
hate Jews, dude. This was literally
Nick. This is Nick literally 30 seconds
ago. 30 seconds before Nick wrote the
this tweet. He was writing like this. He
was writing this exact tweet to someone
else because they defended. Just say you
hate Jews, dude. Just say you want to
murder Jews in the street, you spot the
embassy shooting, dude. That's what Nick
was writing two seconds before this
tweet came in.
What part is wrong, lol? Why are you on
defense for dog zapping sex pest? Weird.
Hill to die on. You tell him to go back
to his little cartoons cuz he's right
and you can't argue that. Hey, WTF
happened. You're now defending Hassan
TF.
Oh, he talks about on stream. We're
going to get to watch him see about this
on stream.
As we go, is this type of creator Star
Wars PC sponsors? Oh boy. The real
question is why you still trying to
glaze the sun after everything that's
come out about this dude. Should we
start looking into you creep? Another
one defending him. Spike is not going to
let you suck his dick, dude. He's not
into little girl. He's into little
girls. Not Wow. Lots of stuff, man.
Okay. And here's these [__] retards
thinking they're any better. There are
like so many documented lies from Nick's
garage. This is so funny, man.
You the same people. You're all the
same. You all the same. Is he live yet?
Or do you cover this last night?
No, he wasn't live last night. Okay.
Well, we'll see. We'll see if we get
him. If you If you've got last night's
Nick Vod and he talked about this on
there, then please send it to me. Why do
I hate Nick? Cuz he's a despicable
[__] liar. Cuz he's a despicable
[__] lowife liar.
ridiculous [__] hypocrite who you can
literally trace through like direct
contradictions between his Ethan Klein
coverage just like two years ago and his
Ethan Klein coverage two weeks ago where
he's just like blatantly contradicting
himself and abandoning his values
because he's a [__] loser who the
moment anyone says that to him, he shuts
down and starts freaking the [__] out to
the point where he's auditing all of his
friends for connections with me.
Desperately worried that I may be
speaking to someone and getting
information or turning them against him.
literally auditing and [__] quizzing
his friends like, "What you think
screaming about that?
Total paranoid [__] loser." Maybe that
that that's part of why I hate him.
That's part of why I hate him.
Okay, so guys, we're tuning in to FFWN
here for a bit. Let's see what's being
said. Respond to these absolute drone
tweets he was receiving. Let's see. How
isn't it going to cope with the fact
that this is the exact way that he's
been behaving the whole time and you
know him and No [__] stones throw
apart?
>> Um,
dude, this is like controlled
opposition. There's absolutely zero
credible evidence that raped a
15-year-old in a brothel.
>> You're like a bad person if you push
this uh if you push this. Like this is
insane.
Like you could say he went to a diddy
party because objectively he did go to a
diddy party, right? Um, now that
implication could be a little bit weary,
but there's absolutely zero evidence.
There's zero credible allegations that
he [__] uh raped a 15-year-old at a
brothel. I think people who post this
are instantly discrediting themselves. I
think Teone looks like a [__] [__]
for reposting this. I think Nux Taku
looks like a psychopath for posting
this. Uh, but the reason why I'm showing
this right now, dude, I'm It's still
like, dude, I don't know what
>> Nick not getting the ethos of the
wiggler will never knock me, dude.
That's Nick with every like inside joke
that he adopts. He just doesn't
understand it at all and just like
starts doing it.
He is like terminally the the fat kid in
the frat house. Like is like terminally
that mindset. The fat kid in the frat
house trying to fit in. That is his
whole [__] life. what this was. There
has been no one who is like no one
meaningful. No offense if the audience
members retweeted it, but nobody with a
following has retweeted this and it got
hoarded. It's at 90 replies about two
hours ago. I wrote in my chat and it was
at 50 and it's like every few minutes
another post is popping up on here and
it's like the most insane replies I've
ever seen. I don't even think this is
like that aggressive. Go back to
watching your little cartoons. What the
[__] is this tweet? Are you on per
controlled opposition which by the way
implies right that the argument is so
bad it's it's helping Assan look good
then it's being misinterpreted as like a
overall defense of Assan per look at the
kind of responses under this tweet look
at this one um you should buy a rope
[laughter]
uh why are you trying to glaze Hassan
after everything that has come out about
this dude this is why I'm thinking this
is like a bot this is like an insane
[__] Impossible.
>> It probably isn't botting.
>> It's not. I don't think it's botting. I
went through a few of these accounts. I
did not see the markings of bots.
>> I was going through a few earlier when I
saw him tweeting about this. I did not
see bot accounts. Usually with bot
accounts, you see a lot of stuff about
crypto and web 3 on there and they'll be
retweeting stuff all at the same time
because they're being bought from like a
botnet or stuff like that. You'll see.
Um, didn't see any sign they were bots.
They just seem like, you know, [__]
Asmin Gold types.
>> But it's You should go back to watching
the sort of people Nick's been making
content for for the last year and a
half.
>> While the adults speak.
>> Oh, no. This is a joke at the expense of
um at Knucks. Hamas hiker is not going
to let you suck his dick. He's into
little girls and not furs. Thank you
guys for the goal.
>> Frog frog. Heart fire. Heart fire. Heart
fire. Think
>> it's like you have no idea whose [__]
account you're posting on. This is like
bizarre. Then this one is is adding
Asmin Gold to try to get me dropped from
my [__] affiliate link.
I I mean, sure. Okay, cool. That's
awesome, dude. Uh, this guy's implying
that I'm a [__] pedophile. You're way
you're running defense for a terrorist
dog zapping sex pest. Weird heal. Oh, I
don't think I screenshotted that one.
Oh, here. Just say that you hate Jews is
another one. Uh, the real question is
why are you trying to glaze this on
everything that's come out? Should we
start looking into you creep? So they're
implying I'm a pedo. They're asking for
my [__] affiliates to be removed.
This guy's tweeting that I hate Jews.
And all of this is happening in like
rapid succession at an interval of like
one reply every 3 minutes hours after
this tweet came up. Um [laughter]
you tell him to go back to his little
cartoons because he's right and you
can't argue that. Wait, you're defending
Hassan [__] Mate trying to defend
Hamas Diddy [__] This is insane.
But um and notice this tweet, this tweet
doesn't seem to have that. I I it's it's
[__] beyond weird to me. Uh my guess
is that somebody added me added this
post in like a Discord server. In 2021,
most of his posts were just ah I can't
show sexing on stream. Um [laughter]
I don't know what that was, but I'm not
risking it. So I thought that was
interesting. Yeah, I think people like
this are pieces of [__] Uh and they
make everybody else around them look
dumber. This is like a Boaxian argument
that you'd find on Twitter before the
guy has like a seismic mental breakdown,
but unfortunately Nuaku is like a wildly
successful content creator who can just
get away with lying. So I I understand
that uh Hassan has lied about Nu. Of
course Nick would never lie. Nick would
never lie in his criticisms of Hassan or
Denims or anyone else. He would
certainly not obiscate cover for Ethan
maliciously edit and we're using a
maliciously edited clip and then lying
about the context of it. He would c he
would certainly never cover up a whole
bunch of lies that Ethan's told. He
would certainly never go on Twitter and
pretend that the club was different to
what it was to try and quilt people's
disagreements, you know. No, no, he
would never do any of that cuz Nick does
it honestly. Nick does it the right way.
Taco, it just makes everybody else look
bad. People replying to this like,
"Every person of this drama sucks." And
it didn't really hit me how annoying
these people are until this interaction.
Oh yeah, this is like the one I I saw
this on my timeline.
That's you. These people just you and
your
>> fans sometimes this is a both sides type
moment. This is actually [__]
depraved.
>> Um yeah. What's he lying about? Uh
there's there's absolutely zero credible
allegations of Hassan [__] raping a
15-year-old at a brothel. That's a just
a flatout lie. Like a flatout defamatory
lie. Um so yeah, that's a pretty easy
one. But anyways,
that's the thing I wanted for the
stream. Also, I wanted to promote this
because I didn't stream last night and I
wanted to raid into it. Uh, but I did
not stream.
>> And look, it's chat man. Doesn't sound
do the same thing?
>> Yeah. I um [laughter]
I I saw that Mer uploaded a new 17-hour
video on Star Wars Outlaws.
>> Wow. Hell say he talks about it more
later. How many How many hours of the
Idubbbz [__] is that after?
How how many hours into watching Idubbbz
is that? How many hours into staring at
Ana J's tits is that?
God, I I [__] hate her so much. God,
I [__] I hate I hate her so much. I
hate her so
I'm just sitting Look at her all all
day. Look at her all day. Look at these
old videos when she's younger and she's
got her tits out cuz I just hate her so
much. I just hate her so [__] much.
And I would never ever [__] her.
104 reply. Why? The guy who allegedly
raped a 15-year-old in a brothel is on
here. It's absolutely [__]
delusional. What do we got here? Why are
you defending Hassan? You're defending a
dog abuser. Why are you defending Hassan
[__] Hey, Oreo, what does Hassan's
dick taste like? You're not saying he's
wrong. Uh, you don't like facts about
Hassan [__] That's such a weird tweet.
Okay, Nuaku's out here spitting facts.
Right message, awful measure. Uh, what
about the post is wrong. People in the
reply says, "Don't know what Nick is."
Destiny accusing Hassan. That scares me
most. Uh, Hassan is also allegedly in
cahoots with George Soros. Maybe it's
personal, man. I don't know. Not hard to
figure it out. Uh, the money ran out.
This is the new grift. He's an Israeli
Jew. That one's actually about Nuaku.
Um,
let's see. Well, it's true. Fat. He's
not wrong. Uh, unaware. Nux's family.
again. Okay, that doesn't make this
correct.
>> Um,
>> uh, hello, Nick.
>> Well, it's true. Fat. He's not wrong.
Uh, unaware NX's family. I I
>> So, this person's when Knox had family
dying. But wait, Nick, you're really
like tone policing how Knox talks about
his support for Israel and his hatred of
Hassan when he's literally a Jew from
Israel. when he's literally a Jew from
Israel. Like Ela and Ethan. Like Ela and
Ethan. He's literally a Jew from Israel
and you're going to tone police he talks
about Israel. Really, Nick? Really,
Nick? I can't believe you're doing this.
Like that's the whole last year of your
content, you [__] idiot.
The whole basis for siding with Ethan
for these [__] idiots in the first
place was that Oh, guys, I understand
that Ethan said Frogan's family should
be shot, killed, and burned in front of
her, but uh what you have to understand
is that uh you see, she said this tweet
about how October 7th was an act of
resistance. So, you have to understand
that can really upset Ethan. That could
really upset Ethan. So, it's like fine
that he totally sped the [__] out and
had a total meltdown and violated a
bunch of norms that we would totally
that we would usually uphold. It's
actually fine that he did that because
he's a Jew from Israel. He's a Jew and
his wife's a Jew from Israel.
That's the whole [__] basis for your
view on this over the last two years.
You stupid fat [__] You stupid [__]
[__] You fw.
You stupid FFW.
Where has that gone, Nick?
>> Again. Okay, that doesn't make this
correct. Um, let's see.
Guy so gay. Shock collars for imagine
hating the guy so much that you're spite
driven idiots like you. Clap like seals.
Um, pretty obvious he's being sarcastic.
Maybe you're autistic or something. I'm
just curious like, yeah, I understand.
Maybe the chatter was caught defending
Hassan Per. Where's the lie? Is Nick a
troll? I thought you hated Hassan. What
part is wrong? You're a [__] All
right, just say you hate Jews. Um, dude
is terrified of Naktaku. What did he say
was wrong, mate? Trying to defend Hamas
Diddy [__]
>> This is you and your friends, bro.
>> Why are you running?
>> This is you, your friends, your fans.
This is you. This is just you.
>> For a terrorist dog pack. Uh, sorry. Dog
zapping sex pest. Weird hill to die on.
I don't understand the problem with
Nux's tweet. Nux, let's ratio this guy.
taking some in the ass. Uh, tell him to
go back to cartoons because he's right.
Uh, you know what the tweet is about.
Get your head out of your ass. Shut the
[__] up, moonshaped jackass. Sadly, he
stated fact. Ride Hassan's dick some
more. Every time there's a factual
thought, you're not refuting it. Uh,
it's crazy how we have more evidence of
Okay, that's not one that's going to be
There are other comments here that are
going after Knox. Uh, I get it. Knucks
is a [__] but what is what is your
tweet about this? Um, is he wrong?
>> Yeah. Which argument
is there any part of this tweet Nick
agrees with? I don't think Nick has the
knowledge to agree with this, does he?
So, allegedly raped a 15-year-old in a
brothel. Okay, Nick can take a stance on
that. That's drama. Okay, that's drama.
That's a rape that happened in Germany.
So, that's drama. Went to diddy parties.
Okay, diddy. That's a rape. That's
That's rapes that happened in America.
Nick can talk about that.
That's drama.
Called the cops to do wellness checks on
XGFs. Okay, that's happened in America.
That's drama.
Supports her mass mass rapists. Now,
Nick can't take a stance on any of this
cuz this is politics. This is politics.
So, Nick can't take a stance on any of
this. So, he would surely never say
something like Hassan supports Hamas or
supports supports terrorists. So, and he
certainly wouldn't take a stance on the
mass rape question because that's quite
a complex geopolitical thing. That's
quite a complex like um it's a
geopolitical thing where you have to
read through a UN report and understand
like distinctions between
circumstantial, forensic, direct
evidence, all these different ideas,
understand what arguments people are
making, weigh in on the value of those
arguments. So Nick would surely never
because that type of rape happened in
some desert country. That's politics. So
he would surely never weigh in on that.
So he doesn't agree with that. Supports
Houthies.
Now Hassan did say once 10 toes down I
support the Houthies. But he was saying
it in the context of a specific military
action. So that's quite political. So I
don't think there's no way Nick would
ever agree with that. Supports
Hezbollah. I don't know that he's ever
say supports Hezbollah. I think he has
said he has no he has he has no major
issues with Hezbollah. Hezbollah was his
his statement. Something like that. He
said to Nick, I think he goes like uh
let's just say I don't have any major
issues with Hezbollah or some [__] like
that. I think he believes he says so
that's quite complicated and Nick
wouldn't weigh on that. So, so Nick
basically
doesn't agree with any of these cuz this
one's drama and isn't substantiated and
this one's drama but is mis misleading.
So Nick actually thinks this whole tweet
is a lie, doesn't he? So I would like
Nick to say he thinks this whole tweet
is a lie. 104 reply. Why? The guy who
allegedly raped a 15year-old in a
brothel is on here. It's absolutely
[__] delusional. What do we got here?
Why are you defending Hassan? You're
defending a dog abuser. Why are you
defending Hassan [__] Hey, Oreo, what
does Hassan's dick taste like? You're
not saying he's wrong. Uh, you don't
like facts about Hassan [__] That's
such a weird tweet. Okay, Naku's out
here spitting facts. Right message,
awful measure. Uh, what about the post
is wrong. People in the reply says don't
know what Nick is. Destiny accusing
Hassan. That scares me most. Uh, Hassan
is also allegedly in cahoots with George
Soros. Maybe it's personal, man. I don't
know. Not hard to figure it out. Uh, the
money ran out. This is the new grift.
He's an Israeli Jew. That one's actually
about Nuaku.
Um,
>> yeah, this is what you would say about
Ethan Nick.
>> Let's see. Well, it's true. Fat. He's
not wrong. Uh, unaware. Nucks his family
again. Okay, it doesn't make this
correct. Um, let's see. Guy so gay.
Shock collars. Imagine hating the guy so
much that your spite driven idiots like
you clap like seals. Um, pretty obvious
he's being sarcastic. Maybe you're
autistic or something. I'm just curious
like, yeah, I understand. Maybe the
chatter was caught defending Hassan Per.
Where's the lie? Is Nick a troll? I
thought you hated Hassan. What part is
wrong? You're a [__] All right. Just
say you hate Jews. Um, dude is terrified
of Nuaku. What did he say was wrong?
Mate trying to defend Hamas Diddy [__]
Uh, why are you running defense for a
terrorist dog pack? Uh, sorry. dog
zapping sex pest. Weird hill to die on.
I don't understand the problem with
Nux's tweet. Nux, let's ratio this guy.
Taking some in the ass. Uh, tell him to
go back to cartoons cuz he's right. Uh,
you know what the tweet is about. Get
your head out of your ass. Shut the [__]
up, moonshaped jackass. Sadly, he stated
fact. Ride Hassan's dick some more.
Every time there's a factual thought,
you're not refuting it. Uh, it's crazy
how we have more evidence of Okay,
that's not one that's going to be There
are other comments here that are going
after Knox. Uh, I get it. Knox is a
[__] but what is act What is your
tweet about this? Um, is he wrong? Uh,
and let me see. You're a [__] Hassan
[__] dick sucker. Let's see. You should
not be on the algorithm. Are you a
Hassan [__] glazer?
Hassan's not going to let you suck his
dick. He's into little girls, not fs
slurs. I think this one is just telling
me to kill myself and buy some rope.
>> Um,
>> literally these people are worth on this
[__] drama. [__] on Hassan [__]
Uh, what else do we got here?
>> Nick Dioro being pro- Hassan [__] Are
you a [__] [__] He's a [__] Nepo
baby. Blah blah blah blah blah. There
were people, I think we covered it in
the other tweet where they were adding
Asmin Gold demanding that he drop that I
get dropped from my affiliate with Star
Forge over this. Um, there were people
implying that I was a pedophile. Uh,
because I
>> Yeah, these are my favorite Nick Dorio
segments where he spends like 30 minutes
at a time reading endless hate comments
>> because I was arguing this talking
point. Uh, the neck one was there for
sure. Just say you hate Jews. So yeah,
there I mean there are completely
[__] people who will engage with bad
faith arguments because they hate
somebody religiously. And then when it
comes down to it, their audiences just
completely disregard everything
everybody says because there's so much
[__] that it's impossible to parse
what's real. So yeah, I mean, I don't
know. There are a lot of brainwashed
retards here. If you think that
everybody who disagrees with Hassan
[__] is a good guy, you're probably
wrong and the audience is probably uh
just as toxic in some capacity. He's not
making everything up. This is terrible.
What happened? I'm not the one who This
crash out is cringey. Well, see you
never thrust my pee pee at Jillwig's
girlfriend, all right, in some form of
weird sexual harassment. Like, I don't
know, bro.
>> And he came in. He said, "You can see my
dick in this." And I said, "Hassan, I'm
not looking." And then he proceeded to
hump the air and he said, "Look." And I
said, "I'm not looking."
>> That's crass.
>> Oh, my personal issues are bad.
I mean, I'm not going to do this. I'm
not going to read it off, but I could.
Let's say that there's a Let's say
there's a hypothetical YouTuber named
Guambo. Uh, Guambo is a pedophile who
raped a 15-year-old girl.
All right, go tweet about the allegation
now. Dude, apparently Guambo did this.
So, then a chatter talks. Apparently,
Guambo has been credibly accused of of
raping a 15-year-old girl.
Okay, Jambo. Yeah, he has a knife and he
raped.
Holy [__]
It was
>> Does he see the anymore
>> pro out for driving?
>> Wait, here we go. Maybe here
>> in the car cuz your car has UV
protective uh glass. So, all that means
is you're just looking through regular
glasses. They're not any more dangerous
than just driving without sunglasses.
Uh, but that's a limitation that you
understand when you get them. Now, I
went and I got like lenses from
Lensology and I put them in my glasses
and stuff because I wanted to try.
>> Wow. Great. Wow. Well, that's that's the
uh FFWN update.
Great stuff happening as he looks into a
mirror. As you'd expect, he doesn't like
what he sees.